the following is a conversation with
Leslie Kayla bling
she's a roboticist and professor at MIT
she's recognized for her work and
reinforcement learning planning robot
navigation and several other topics in
AI she won the edge KY computers and
thought award and was the
editor-in-chief of the prestigious
journal machine learning research this
conversation is part of the artificial
intelligence podcast at MIT and beyond
if you enjoy it subscribe on youtube
itunes or simply connect with me on
twitter at Lex Friedman spelled Fri D
and now here's my conversation with
Leslie Kael Blaine what made me get
excited about AI I can say that as I
read girdle Ashur back when I was in
high school that was pretty formative
for me because it exposed the
interestingness of primitives and
combination and how you can make complex
things out of simple parts and ideas of
AI and what kinds of programs might
generate intelligent behavior so so you
first fell in love with AI reasoning
logic versus robots
yeah the robots came because my first
job so I finished an undergraduate
degree in philosophy at Stanford and was
about to finish master's in computer
science and I got hired at SR I in their
AI lab and they were building a robot it
was a kind of a follow-on to shaky but
all the shaky people were not there
anymore
and so my job was to try to get this
robot to do stuff and that's really kind
of what got me interested in robots so
maybe taking a small step back your
bachelor's in Stanford and philosophy
did masters and PhD in computer science
but the bachelors in philosophy so what
was that journey like what elements of
philosophy do you think you bring to
your work in computer science so the
part of the reason that I didn't do a
computer science undergraduate degree
was that there wasn't one at Stanford at
the time but that there's part of
philosophy and in fact Stanford has a
special sub major in something called
now symbolic systems which is logic
model theory formal semantics of natural
language and so that's actually a
perfect preparation for work in AI and
computer science that that's kind of
interesting so if you were interested in
artificial intelligence what what kind
of majors were people even thinking
about taking what is it in your science
was so besides philosophies what were
you supposed to do if you were
fascinated by the idea of creating
intelligence there weren't enough people
who did that for that even to be at
conversation okay I mean I think
probably probably philosophy I mean it's
interesting in my class my graduating
class of undergraduate philosophers
probably maybe slightly less
than half went on in computer science
slightly less than half went on in law
and like one or two went on in
philosophy so it was a common kind of
connection do you think AI researchers
have a role be part time philosophers or
should they stick to the solid science
and engineering without sort of taking
the philosophizing tangents I mean you
work with robots you think about what it
takes to create intelligent beings
aren't you the perfect person to think
about the big picture philosophy of it
all the parts of philosophy that are
closest to AI I think or at least the
closest to AI that I think about are
stuff like belief and knowledge and
denotation and that kind of stuff and
that's you know it's quite formal and
it's like just one step away from the
kinds of computer science work that we
do kind of routinely I think that there
are important questions still about what
you can do with a machine and what you
can't and so on although at least my
personal view is that I'm completely a
materialist and I don't think that
there's any reason why we can't make a
robot be behaviorally indistinguishable
from a human and the question of whether
it's in the distinguishable internally
whether it's a zombie or not in
philosophy terms
I actually don't I don't know and I
don't know if I care too much about that
right there there's a philosophical
notions they're mathematical and
philosophical because we don't know so
much of how difficult it is how
difficult is a perception problem how
difficult is the planning problem how
difficult is it to operate in this world
successfully because our robots are not
currently as successful human beings and
many tasks the the question about the
gap between current robots and human
beings borders a little bit on
philosophy you know the expanse of
knowledge that's required to operate in
this world and the ability to form
common-sense knowledge the ability to
reason about uncertainty much of the
work you've been doing there's those
open questions there that I don't know
require to activate a certain
big-picture view to me that doesn't seem
like a philosophical gap
to me it's a there is a big technical
gap yes technical gap but I don't see
any reason why it's more than a
technical gap perfect so when you
mention AI you know sorry
and maybe can you describe to me when
you first fell in love with robotics
with robots or inspired which so you
should mention flaky or shaky shaky
flaky and what was the robot that first
captured your imagination what's
possible right well this so the first
robot I worked was like shakey was a
robot that the SR I people had built but
by the time I think when I arrived it
was sitting in a corner of somebody's
office dripping hydraulic fluid into a
pan but its iconic and really everybody
should read the shaky tech report
because it has so many good ideas in it
I mean they invented a star search and
symbolic planning and learning macro
operators they had the level kind of
configuration space planning for the
robot they had vision they had all this
the basic ideas of a ton of things okay
take a step by the shaky have arms that
was a job could push objects and so it
would move things around with which
actuator itself with its base okay so it
could but it and they had painted the
baseboards black so it used it used
vision to localize itself in a map it
detected objects it could detect objects
that were surprising to it it would plan
and re plan based on what it saw it
reasoned about whether to look and take
pictures I mean it really had the basics
of of so many of the things that we
think about now how do you represent the
space around it so it had
representations that are bunch of
different levels of abstraction so it
had I think a kind of an occupancy grid
of some sort at the lowest level at the
high level it was abstract symbolic kind
of rooms and connectivity it's a word as
flaky coming yeah okay so
at us RI and we were building a
brand-new robot as I said none of the
people from the previous project were
kind of there or involved anymore so we
were kind of starting from scratch and
my advisor was Stan resin shine he ended
up being my thesis advisor and he was
motivated by this idea of situated
computation or situated automata and the
idea was that the tools of logical
reasoning were important but possibly
only for the engineers or designers to
use in the analysis of a system but not
necessarily to be manipulated in the
head of the system itself right so I
might use logic to prove a theorem about
the behavior of my robot even if the
robots not using logic and it's headed
to prove theorems right so that was kind
of the distinction and so the idea was
to kind of use those principles to make
a robot do stuff but a lot of the basic
things we had to kind of learn for
ourselves because I had zero background
in robotics I didn't know anything about
control I don't know anything about
sensors so we reinvented a lot of wheels
on the way to getting that robot to do
stuff do you think that was an advantage
or hindrance
oh no it's I mean I I'm big in favor of
wheel reinvention actually I mean I
think you learn a lot by doing it it's
important though to eventually have the
pointers to so that you can see what's
really going on but I think you can
appreciate much better the good
solutions
once you've messed around a little bit
on your own and found a bad one yeah I
think you mentioned reinventing
reinforcement learning yeah and
referring to rewards as pleasures by a
pleasure yeah I think yeah I think it's
a nice name for it it's more it's more
fun almost do you think you could tell
the history of AI and machine learning
reinforcement learning and how you think
about it from the 50s to now one thing
is that its oscillates right so things
become fashionable and then they go out
and then something else becomes cool and
that it goes out and so on and I think
there's so there's some interesting
sociological process that actually
drives
a lot of what's going on early days was
kind of cybernetics and control right
and the idea that of homeostasis people
have made these robots that could I
don't know try to plug into the wall
when they needed power and then come
loose and roll around and do stuff and
then I think over time the thought well
that was inspiring but people said no no
we want to get maybe closer to what
feels like real intelligence or human
intelligence and then maybe the expert
systems people tried to do that but
maybe a little too superficially right
so oh we get the surface understanding
of what intelligence is like because I
understand how a steel mill works and I
can try to explain it to you and you can
write it down in logic and then we can
make a computer infer that and then that
didn't work out but what's interesting I
think is when a thing starts to not be
working very well it's not only do we
change methods we change problems right
so it's not like we have better ways of
doing the problem of the experts those
people are trying to do we have no ways
of trying to do that problem oh yeah I
know I think maybe a few but we kind of
give up on that problem and we switch to
a different problem and we we work that
for a while and we I guess there's a
broad community as a community and
there's a lot of people who would argue
you don't give up on the problem it's
just you decrease the number of people
working on it you almost kind of like
put it on the shelf
so we'll come back to this 20 years
later yeah I think that's right or you
might decide that it's malformed like
you might say it's wrong to just try to
make something that does superficial
symbolic reasoning behave like a doctor
you can't do that until you've had the
sensorimotor experience of being a
doctor or something right so there's
arguments that say that that's problem
was not well formed or it could be that
it is well for it but but we just
weren't approaching it well you mention
that your favorite part of logic and
symbolic systems is that they give short
names for large sets
so there is some use to this they use
just as a symbolic reasoning though the
looking at expert systems and symbolic
computing what do you think are the
roadblocks that were hit in the eighties
and nineties ah okay so right so the
fact that I'm not a fan of expert
systems doesn't mean that I'm not a fan
of some kinds of symbolic reasoning
right so let's see road blocks but the
main road block I think was that the
idea that humans could articulate their
knowledge effectively into into you know
some kind of logical statements so it's
not just the cost the effort but really
just the capability of doing it right
because we're all experts in vision
right but not totally don't have
introspective access into how we do that
right and it's true that I mean I think
the idea was well of course even people
then would know of course I wouldn't ask
you to please write down the rules that
you use for recognizing water bottle
that's crazy and everyone understood
that but we might ask you to please
write down the rules you use for
deciding I don't know what tie to put on
or how to set up a microphone or
something like that but even those
things I think people maybe I think what
they found I'm not sure about this but I
think what they found was that that
so-called experts could give
explanations that sort of post hoc
explanations for how and why they did
things but they weren't necessarily very
good and then they different they
depended on maybe some kinds of
perceptual things which again they
couldn't really define very well so I
think I think fundamentally I think that
the underlying problem with that was the
assumption that people could articulate
how and why they make their decisions
all right so it's almost in call
encoding the knowledge from converting
from expert to something that a machine
could understand and reason with no no
not even just encoding but getting it
out of you just not not writing it I
mean yes hard also to write it down for
the computer yeah but I don't think that
but can produce it you can tell me a
story about why you do stuff but I'm not
so sure that's the way great so there
are still on the hierarchical planning
side places where symbolic reasoning is
very useful so as you've talked about so
where so don't where's the gap yeah okay
good so saying that humans can't provide
a description of their reasoning
processes that's ok fine but that
doesn't mean that it's not good to do
reasoning of various styles inside a
computer those are just two orthogonal
points so then the question is what kind
of reasoning should you do inside a
computer right and the answer is I think
you need to do all different kinds of
reasoning inside a computer depending on
what kinds of problems you face I guess
the question is what kind of things can
you encode symbolically so you can
reason about I think the idea about an
even symbolic I don't even like that
terminology because I don't know what it
means
technically informally I do believe in
abstractions so abstractions are
critical right you cannot reason a
completely fine grain about everything
in your life right you can't make a plan
at the level of images and torques for
getting a PhD right so you have to
reduce the size of the state space and
you have to reduce the horizon if you're
gonna reason about getting a PhD or even
buying the ingredients to make dinner
and so so how can you reduce the spaces
and the horizon of the reasoning you
have to do and the answer is abstraction
spatial abstraction temporal abstraction
I think abstraction along the lines of
goals is also interesting like you might
or well abstraction and decomposition
goals this may be more of a
decomposition thing so I think that's
where these kinds of if you want to call
it symbolic or discrete models come in
you you talk about a room of your house
instead of your pose you talk about
you know doing something during the
afternoon instead of at 2:54 and you do
that because it makes your reasoning
problem easier and also because you have
you don't have enough information to
reason in high fidelity about your pose
of your elbow at 2:35 this afternoon
anyway right when you're trying to get a
PhD okay except for at that moment at
that moment you do have to use it about
the pose of your elbow maybe but then
you maybe you do that in some continuous
joint space kind of modeling so I again
I my biggest point about all of this is
that there should be the dogma is not
the thing right we shouldn't it
shouldn't be that I'm in favor against
symbolic reasoning and you're in favor
against neural networks it should be
that just just computer science tells us
what the right answer to all these
questions is smart enough to figure it
out
oh yeah when you try to actually solve
the problem with computers the right
answer comes out you mentioned
abstractions mm-hmm I mean you all
networks form abstractions or rather
there's there's automated ways to form
strategies and there's expert driven
ways to form abstractions and export
human driven ways and humans just seems
to be way better at forming abstractions
currently and certain problems so when
you're referring to 2:45 and PM versus
afternoon how do we construct that
taxonomy is there any room for automated
construction of such abstractions oh I
think eventually yeah I mean I think
when we get to be better and machine
learning engineers will build algorithms
that build awesome abstractions that are
useful in this kind of way that you
describe yeah yeah so let's then step
from the the abstraction discussion and
let's talk about BOM mdps partially
observable Markov decision processes so
uncertainty so first water Markov
decision processes and maybe how much of
our world could be models and mdps how
much when you wake up in them
morning me making breakfast how do you
think of yourself as an MDP so how do
you think about MVPs and how they relate
to our world well so there's a stance
question right so a stance is a position
that I take with respect to a problem so
I as a researcher or person who design
systems can decide to make a model of
the world around me
in some terms right so I take this messy
world and I say I'm gonna treat it as if
it were a problem of this formal kind
and then I can apply solution concepts
around rhythms or whatever to solve that
formal thang right so of course the
world is not anything it's not an MDP or
a pom DP I don't know what it is but I
can model aspects of it in some way or
some other way and when I model some
aspect of it in a certain way that gives
me some set of algorithms I can use you
can model the world in all kinds of ways
some have some are more accepting of
uncertainty more easily modeling
uncertainty of the world some really
force the world to be deterministic
and so the certainly NDP's model the
uncertainty of the world yes model some
uncertainty the model not present state
uncertainty but they model uncertainty
in the way the future will unfold right
so what are Markov decision process so
marketers process is a model it's a kind
of model that you could make that says I
I know completely the current state of
my system and what it means to be a
state is that I that all they have all
the information right now that will let
me make predictions about the future as
well as I can so that remembering
anything about my history wouldn't make
my predictions any better and but it but
then it also says that that then I can
take some actions that might change the
state of the world and that I don't have
a deterministic model of those changes I
have a probabilistic model of how the
world might change it's a it's a useful
model for some kinds of systems I think
it's a I mean it's certainly not a good
model for most problems I think because
for most problems you don't actually
know
State for most problems you it's
partially observed so that's now a
different problem class so okay that's
where the poverty P is the partially
observable Markov decision process step
n so how do they address the fact that
you can't observe most your incomplete
information about most of the world
around you right so now the idea is we
still kind of postulate that there
exists a state we think that there is
some information about the world out
there such that if we knew that we could
make good predictions but we don't know
the state and so then we have to think
about how but we do get observations
maybe I get images right here things are
I feel things and those might be local
or noisy and so therefore they don't
tell me everything about what's going on
and then I have to reason about given
the history of actions I've taken in
observations I've gotten what do I think
is going on in the world and then given
my own kind of uncertainty about what's
going on in the world I can decide what
actions to take and so difficult is this
problem of planning under uncertainty in
your view and you know long experience
of modeling the world trying to deal
with this uncertainty in special and
real of all systems optimal planning for
even discrete hamdi peas can be
undecidable depending on how you set it
up and free so lots of people say I
don't use pom D peas because they are
intractable and I think that that's are
kind of a very funny thing to say
because the problem you have to solve is
the problem you have to solve so if the
problem you have to solve is intractable
that's what makes us AI people right so
we saw we understand that the problem
we're solving is is compute wildly
intractable that we can't we will never
be able to solve it optimally at least I
don't yeah right so later we can come
back to an idea about bounded optimality
and something but anyway I don't we
can't come up with optimal solutions to
these problems so we have to make
approximations approximations in
modeling approximations in the solution
algorithms and so on and so I don't have
a problem with saying yeah my problem
actually it is pom DP
in continuous space with continuous
observations and it's so computationally
complex I can't even think about it's
you know Big O whatever but that doesn't
prevent me from it helps me gives me
some clarity to think about it that way
and to then take steps to make
approximation after approximation to get
down to something that's like computable
in some reasonable time when you think
about optimality you know the community
broadly is shifted on that I think a
little bit in how much they value the
idea of optimality of chasing an optimal
solution positive views of chasing an
optimal solution changed over the years
and when you work with robots that's
interesting I think we have a little bit
of a methodological crisis actually from
the theoretical side I mean I do think
that theory is important in that right
now we're not doing much of it so
there's lots of empirical hacking around
and training this and doing that and
reporting numbers but is it good is it
bad we don't know we very hard to say
things
and if you look at like computer science
theory
so people talked for a while everyone
was about solving problems optimally or
completely and and then there were
interesting relaxation so people look at
oh can I are their regret bounds or can
I do some kind of you know approximation
can I prove something that I can
approximately solve this problem or that
I get closer to the solution as I spend
more time and so on what's interesting I
think is that we don't have good
approximate solution concepts for very
difficult problems right I like to you
know I like to say that I I'm interested
in doing a very bad job of very big
problems but I would I wish I could say
something I wish I had a I don't know
some kind of a formal solution concept
that I could use to say oh this this
algorithm actually it gives me something
like I know what I'm gonna get I can do
something other than just run it and get
out so that having that notion is still
somewhere deeply compelling to you the
notion that you can say you can drop
thing on the table says this you can
expect this this out gonna give me some
good results
I hope science will I mean there's
engineering in there science I think
that they're not exactly the same and I
think right now we're making huge
engineering like leaps and bounds so
that engineering is running away ahead
of the science which is cool and often
how it goes right so we're making things
and nobody knows how and why they work
roughly but we need to turn that into
science there's some form it's yeah
there's some room for formalizing we
need to know what the principles are why
does this work why does that not work I
mean for awhile people built bridges by
trying but now we can often predict
whether it's going to work or not
without building it can we do that for
learning systems or for robots so your
hope is
from a materialistic perspective that
intelligence artificial intelligence
systems robots okay I were just more
fancier bridges believe space what's the
difference between belief space and
state space I mentioned MDPs fond
appease you reasoning about you sense
the world there's a state
what's this belief space idea I believe
space that is instead of thinking about
what's the state of the world and trying
to control that as a robot I think about
what is the space of beliefs that I
could have about the world what's if I
think of a belief as a probability
distribution over ways the world could
be a belief state is a distribution and
then my control problem if I'm reasoning
about how to move through a world I'm
uncertain about my control problem is
actually the problem of controlling my
beliefs so I think about taking actions
not just what effect they'll have on the
world outside but what effect I'll have
on my own understanding of the world
outside and so that might compel me to
ask a question or look somewhere to
gather information which may not really
change the world state but it changes my
own belief about the world that's a
powerful way to to empower the agent to
reason about the world to explore the
world what kind of problems does it
allow you to solve to to consider belief
space versus just state space well any
problem that requires deliberate
information gathering right so if in
some problems like chess there's no
uncertainty or maybe there's uncertainty
about the opponent there's no
uncertainty about the state and some
problems there's uncertainty but you
gather information as you go right you
might say oh I'm driving my autonomous
car down the road and it doesn't know
perfectly where it is but the Llyod ours
are all going all the time so I don't
have to think about whether to gather
information but if you're a human
driving down the road you sometimes look
over your shoulder to see what's going
on behind you in the lane and you have
to
side whether you should do that now and
you have to trade off the fact that
you're not seeing in front of you and
you're looking behind you and how
valuable is that information and so on
and so to make choices about information
gathering you have to reasonably spaced
also also I mean also to just take into
account your own uncertainty before
trying to do things so you might say if
I understand where I'm standing relative
to the door jamb pretty accurately then
it's okay for me to go through the door
but if I'm really not sure where the
door is then it might be better to not
do that right now
the degree of your uncertainty ball
about the world is actually part of the
thing you're trying to optimize in
forming the plan right so this idea of a
long horizon of planning for a PhD or
just even how to get out of the house or
how to make breakfast you show this
presentation of the the WTF was the fork
of robot looking at a sink and can you
describe how we plan in this world of
this idea of hierarchical planning we've
mentioned this is a yeah how can a robot
hope to plan about something this was
such a long hallway people since
probably reasoning began have thought
about hierarchical reasoning the
temporal hierarchy and particular
spatial hierarchy but let's talk about
temporal hierarchy so you might say oh I
have this long execution I have to do
but I can divide it into some segments
abstractly right so maybe you have to
get out of house I have to get in the
car I have to drive so on and so you can
plan if you can build abstractions so
this we started out by talking about
abstractions and we're back to that now
if you can build abstractions in your
state space and abstractions sort of
temporal abstractions then you can make
plans at a high level and you can say
I'm gonna go to town and then I'll have
to get gas and then I can go here and I
can do this other thing and you can
reason about the dependencies and
constraints among these
actions again without thinking about the
complete details what we do in our
hierarchical planning work is then say
alright I make a plan at a high level of
abstraction I have to have some reason
to think that it's feasible without
working it out in complete detail and
that's actually the interesting step I
always like to talk about walking
through an airport like you can plan to
go to New York and arrive at the airport
and then find yourself in an office
building later you can't even tell me in
advance what your plan is for walking
through the airport
partly because you're too lazy to think
about it maybe but partly also because
you just don't have the information you
don't know what gate you're landing in
or what people are gonna be in front of
you or anything so there's no point in
planning in detail but you have to have
you have to make a leap of faith that
you can figure it out once you get there
and it's really interesting to me how
you arrive at that how do you they say
you have learned over your lifetime to
be able to make some kinds of
predictions about how hard it is to
achieve some kinds of sub goals and
that's critical like you would never
plan to fly somewhere if you couldn't
didn't have a model of how hard it was
to do some of the intermediate steps so
one of the things we're thinking about
now is how do you do this kind of very
aggressive generalization to situations
that you haven't been in and so on to
predict how long will it take to walk
through the Kuala Lumpur Airport like
you give me an estimate and it wouldn't
be crazy and you have to have an
estimate of that in order to make plans
that involve walking through the Kuala
Lumpur Airport even if you don't need to
know it in detail so I'm really
interested in these kinds of abstract
models and how do we acquire them but
once we have them we can use them to do
hierarchical reasoning which is I think
it's very important yeah there's this
notion of gold' regression and preimage
back chaining this idea of starting at
the goal and it's just for these big
clouds of states you get I mean it's
almost like saying to the airport you
know you you know once you show up
to the airport that that's you you're
like a few steps away from the goal so
like thinking of it this way it's kind
of interesting I don't know if you have
sort of further comments on them of
starting at the goal why that yeah I
mean it's interesting that Simon herb
Simon back in the early days of AI did
talked a lot about means-ends reasoning
and reasoning back from the goal there's
a kind of an intuition that people have
that the number of that state space is
big the number of actions you could take
is really big so if you say here I sit
and I want to search forward from where
I am what are all the things I could do
that's just overwhelming if you say if
you can reason at this other level and
say here's what I'm hoping to achieve
what can I do to make that true that
somehow the branching is smaller now
what's interesting is that like in the
AI planning community that hasn't worked
out in the class of problems that they
look at and the methods that they tend
to use it hasn't turned out that it's
better to go backward it's still kind of
my intuition that it is but I can't
prove that to you right now all right
I'd share your intuition at least for us
mere humans speaking of which when you
maybe never take it and take a look take
a little step into that philosophy
circle how hard would it when you think
about human life you should give those
examples often how hard do you think it
is to formulate human life is a planning
problem or aspects of human life so when
you look at robots you're often trying
to think about object manipulation tasks
about moving a thing when you when you
take a slight step outside the room let
the robot leave and go get lunch or
maybe try to pursue more fuzzy goals how
hard do you think is that problem if you
were to try to maybe put another way try
to formulate human life as a planning
problem well that would be a mistake I
mean it's not all the planning problem
right every think it's really really
important that we understand that you
have to put together pieces and parts
that have different styles of reasoning
representation and learning I think I
think it's it's seems probably clear to
anybody that that you you can't all be
this or all be that brains aren't all
like this are all like that right they
have different pieces and parts and
substructure and so on so I don't think
that there's any good reason to think
that there's going to be like one true
algorithmic thing that's gonna do the
whole job just a bunch of pieces
together designed to solve a bunch of
specific problem one the specific styles
of problems I mean there's probably some
reasoning that needs to go on in image
space I think again there's this model
based vs. model free idea it's I only
enforce spent learning people talk about
it oh should I learn I could learn a
policy just straight up a way of
behaving I could learn it's popularly a
value function that's some kind of weird
intermediate ground or I could learn a
transition model or it tells me
something about the dynamics of the
world if I take a trip if imagine that I
learned in a transition model and I
couple it with a planner and I draw a
box around that I have a policy again
it's just stored a different way right
right it's in but it's just as much of a
policy as the other policy it's just
I've made I think the way I see it is
it's a time-space trade-off in
computation right a more overt policy
representation maybe it takes more space
but maybe I can compute quickly what
action I should take on the other hand
maybe a very compact model of the world
dynamics plus a planner
let's make compute what action to take
to just more slowly
there's no I mean I don't think there's
no argument to be had it's just like a
question of what form of computation is
best for us for the various subproblems
right so and and so like learning to do
algebra manipulations for some reason is
good I mean that's probably gonna want
naturally is sort of a different
representation than riding a unicycle at
the time constraints on the unicycle or
serious this thing space is maybe
smaller I don't know
but so I could be
the more human-sized of falling in love
having a relationship that might be
another yeah another style of no idea
how to model that yeah that's let's
first solve the algebra an object may
patient what do you think is harder
perception or planning perception that's
understanding that's so what do you
think is so hard about perception by
understanding the world around you well
I think the big question is
representational a hugely the question
is representation so perception has made
great strides lately right and we can
classify images and we can play certain
kinds of games of predict I to steer in
the car and all this sort of stuff I
don't think we have a very good idea of
what perception should deliver right so
if you if you believe in modularity ok
there's there's a very strong view which
says we shouldn't build in any
modularity we should make a giant
gigantic neural network trained it
end-to-end to do the thing and that's
the best way forward and it's hard to
argue with that except on a sample
complexity basis right so you might say
oh well if I want to do end-to-end Rio
first of all anything on this giant
giant neural network it's going to take
a lot of data and a lot of like broken
robot system so then the only answer is
to say ok we have to build something in
build in some structure or some bias we
know from theory of machine learning the
only way to cut down the sample
complexity is to kind of cut down
somehow cut down the hypothesis space
you can do that by building in bias
there's all kinds of reason to think
that nature built bias into humans
[Music]
convolution is a bias right it's a very
strong bias and it's a very critical
bias so my own view is that we should
look for more things that are like
convolution but that
other aspects of reasoning right so
convolution helps us a lot with a
certain kind of spatial reasoning that's
quite close to the imaging I think
there's other ideas like that maybe some
amount of forward search maybe some
notions of abstraction maybe the notion
that objects exist actually I think
that's pretty important and a lot of
people won't give you that to start with
right so almost like a convolution in
the in the object semantic object space
of some kind sometimes some kind of
ideas in there that's right people who
started like the graph graph
convolutions are an idea that are
related to racial relational
representations and so so I think there
are so you I've come far afield from
perception but I think I think the thing
that's going to make perception that
kind of the next step is actually
understanding better what it should
produce right so what are we going to do
with the output of it right it's fine
when what we're gonna do with the output
is Sudhir it's less clear when we're
just trying to make a one integrated
intelligent agent what should the output
of perception be we have no idea and how
should that hook up to the other stuff
we don't know so I think the pressing
question is what kinds of structure can
we build in that are like the moral
equivalent of convolution that will make
a really awesome super structure that
then learning can kind of progress on
efficiently I agree very compelling
description of actually where we stand
with the perceptual mom you're teaching
a course on embodying intelligence what
do you think it takes to build a robot
with human level intelligence I don't
know if we knew we would do it if you
were to I mean okay so do you think a
robot needs to have a self-awareness
consciousness fear of mortality or is it
is it simpler than that or is
consciousness a simple thing like do you
think about these notions I don't think
much about consciousness even most
philosophers who care about it will give
you that you could have
that are zombies right that behave like
humans but are not conscious and I at
this moment we'd be happy enough for
that so I'm not really worried one way
or the other to the technical side
you're not thinking of the use of
self-awareness no but okay but then what
is self-awareness mean I mean that you
need to have some part of the system
that can observe other parts of the
system and tell whether they're working
well or not that seems critical so does
that count this I mean does that kind of
self-awareness or not well it depends on
whether you think that there's somebody
at home who can articulate whether
they're self-aware but clearly if I have
like you know some piece of code that's
counting how many times this procedure
gets executed that's a kind of
self-awareness right so there's a big
spectrum it's clear you have to have
some of it right
you know quite far away at many
dimensions but there's a direction of
research that's most compelling to you
for you know try to achieve human-level
intelligence in our robots well to me I
guess the thing that seems most
compelling to me at the moment is this
question of what to build in and what to
learn I think we're we don't we're
missing a bunch of ideas and and we you
know people you know don't you dare ask
me how many years it's gonna be until
that happens because I won't even
participate in the conversation because
I think we're missing ideas and I don't
know how long it's gonna take to find
them so I won't ask you how many years
but maybe I'll ask you what it when
you'll be sufficiently impressed that
we've achieved it so what's what's a
good test of intelligence do you like
the Turing test the natural language in
the robotic space is there something
wait you would sit back and think us
that's pretty impressive as a test as a
benchmark do you think about these kinds
of problems no I resist I mean I think
all the time that we spend arguing about
those kinds of things could be better
spent just making the robots work better
so you
competition so I mean there's a nature
of benchmark benchmarks and data sets or
touring test challenges or everybody
kind of gets together and tries to build
a better robot because they want to
compete each other like the DARPA
challenge with the autonomous vehicles
do you see the value of that I can get
in the way I think in the way I mean
some people many people find it
motivating and so that's good
I find it anti motivating but I think I
mean I think you get an interesting
cycle where for a contest a bunch of
smart people get super motivated and
they hack the brains out and much of
what gets done is just hacks but
sometimes really cool ideas emerge and
then that gives us something to chew on
after that so I'm it's not a thing for
me but I don't I don't regret that other
people do it yeah it's like he says with
everything else that makes is good so
jumping topics a little bit
he started the journal of machine
learning research and served as its
editor-in-chief how did the publication
come about and what do you think about
the current publishing model space and
machine learning artificial intelligence
ok good so it came about because there
was a journal called machine learning
which still exists which was owned by
Kluwer and there was I was on the
editorial board and we used to have
these meetings and really where we would
complain to Kluwer that it was too
expensive for the libraries and that
people couldn't publish and we would
really like to have some kind of relief
on those friends and they would always
sympathize but not do anything so we
just decided to make a new journal and
there was the Journal of AI research
which has was on the same model which
had been and exists us for maybe five
years or so and it was going on pretty
well so uh we just made a new journal it
wasn't I mean they don't know I guess it
was work but it wasn't that hard so
basically the editorial board probably
75% of the editorial board of machine
learning resigned and we founded the
Neuse new journal
but it was sort of it was more open yeah
right so it's completely open its open
access actually I I had a postdoc George
Kennedy artists who wanted to call these
journals free for all because there were
I mean it both has no page charges and
has no access restrictions and the
reason and so lots of people I mean
there were there were people who are mad
about the existence of this journal who
thought it was a fraud or something it
would be impossible they said to run a
journal like this with basically I mean
for a long time I didn't even have a
bank account I paid for the lawyer to
incorporate and the IP address and it
cost a couple hundred dollars a year to
run it's a little bit more now but not
that much more but that's because I
think computer scientists are competent
and autonomous in a way that many
scientists and other fields aren't I
mean at doing these kinds of things we
already typeset around papers we all
have students and people who can hack a
website together in an afternoon so the
infrastructure for us was like not a
problem but for other people in other
fields it's a harder thing to do yeah
and this kind of open access journal and
there's nevertheless one of the most
prestigious journals so it's not like a
prestige and it can be achieved without
any other paper it's not required yeah
for prestige it turns out yeah so on the
review process side of actually a long
time ago I don't remember when I
reviewed a paper where you were also a
reviewer and I remember reading your if
you were being influenced by it and it
was really well-written
it influenced how I write future reviews
you disagreed with me actually and you
made it my review but much better so I
but nevertheless the review process you
know has its flaws and how do you think
what do you think works well how can it
be improved so actually when I started
Djamel our I wanted to do something
completely different
and I didn't because it felt like we
needed a traditional Journal of record
and so we just made jam art be almost
like a normal Journal except for the
open-access parts of it basically
increasingly of course publication is
not even a sensible word you can publish
something about putting it in archives
that I can publish everything tomorrow
so making stuff public is there's no
barrier we still need curation and
evaluation I don't have time to read all
of our kyv and you could argue that kind
of social thumbs up being of articles
suffice is right you might say oh heck
with this we don't need journals at all
we'll put everything on archive and
people will upload and down about the
articles and then your CV will say oh
man they he got a lot of buzz so that's
good but I think there's still value in
careful reading and commentary of things
and it's hard to tell when people are
voting and down voting or arguing about
your paper on Twitter and reddit whether
they know what they're talking about
right so then I have the second order
problem of trying to decide whose
opinions I should value and such so I
don't know I what I if I had infinite
time which I don't and I'm not gonna do
this because I really want to make
robots work but if I felt inclined to do
something more in a publication
direction I would do this other thing
which I thought about doing the first
time which is to get together some set
of people whose opinions I value and who
were pretty articulate and I guess we
would be public although we could be
private I'm not sure and we would review
papers we wouldn't publish them and you
wouldn't submit them we were just fine
papers and we would write reviews and we
would make those reviews public and
maybe if you you know so we're Leslie's
friends who review papers and maybe
eventually if if we are
opinion was officially valued like the
opinion of Jay mor is valued then you'd
say in your CV that Leslie's friends
gave my paper a five-star reading and
that would be just as good as saying I
got it so you know accepted into this
journal so I think I think we should
have good public commentary and organize
it in some way but I don't really know
how to do it it's interesting at times
the way the way you describe text is
really interesting and you would do it
for movies IMDB done know there's
experts critics come in they write
reviews but there's also regular yeah
non critics humans write reviews and
they're separated I like open review the
the eye I cleared
process I think is interesting it's a
step in the right direction but it's
still not as compelling as reviewing
movies or video games I mean it
sometimes almost it might be silly it's
my perspective to say but it boils down
to the user interface how fun and easy
it is to actually perform the reviews
how efficient how much you as a reviewer
get street cred for being a good
reviewer those element those human
elements come into play now it's a big
investment to do a good review of a
paper and the flood of papers is that
control right so you know there aren't
3,000 new I don't know how many new
movies are there any year I don't know
but that's probably gonna be less than
how many machine learning papers are in
a year now and I'm worried I you know I
I and right so I'm like an old person so
of course I'm gonna say rawrrr things
are moving too fast I'm a stick in the
mud so I can say that but my particular
flavor of that is I think the horizon
for researchers has gotten very short
that students want to publish a lot of
papers and there's a huge there's value
it's exciting and there's value in that
and you get patted on the head for it
and so on but and some of that is fine
but I'm worried that we're driving out
people who would spend two years
thinking about something back in my day
when we worked on our theses we did not
publish papers you did your thesis for
years
you picked a hard problem and then you
worked and chewed on it and did stuff
and wasted time and a long time and when
it was roughly when it was done you
would write papers and so I I don't know
how to inside and I don't think that
everybody has to work in that mode but I
think there's some problems that are
hard enough that it's important to have
a longer her research horizon and I'm
worried though we don't incentivize that
at all at this point in this current
structure right so what do you see as
what are your hopes and fears about the
future of AI and continuing this theme
so AI has gone through a few winters ups
and downs do you see another winter of
AI coming
are you more hopeful about making robots
work as he said I think the cycles are
inevitable but I think each time we we
get higher right I mean so you know it's
like climbing some kind of landscape
with a noisy optimizer yeah so it's
clear that the the you know the deep
learning stuff has made deep and
important improvements and so the
high-water mark is now higher I there's
no question but of course I think people
are over sawing and eventually investors
I guess and other people look around and
say well you're not quite delivering on
this grand claim and that wild
hypothesis it's so probably it's going
to crash them out and then it's okay I
mean but I don't I can't imagine that
there's like some awesome monotonic
improvement from here to human level III
so in you know I have to ask this
question I probably anticipate answers
the answers but do you have a worry
short term and long term about the
existential
threats of AI and maybe short-term less
existential but more robots taking away
jobs actually let me talk a little bit
about utility actually I had an
interesting conversation with some
military ethicists who wanted to talk to
me about autonomous weapons and there
they were interesting smart
well-educated guys who didn't know too
much about AI are machine learning and
the first question they asked me was has
your robot ever done something you
didn't expect and I like burst out
laughing because anybody who's ever done
something other robot right knows that
they don't do it and what I realized was
that their model of how we program a
robot was completely wrong their model
of how we can put program robot was like
Lego Mindstorms like oh go for it a
meter turn left take a picture do this
do that and so if you have that model of
programming then it's true it's kind of
weird that your robot would do something
that you didn't anticipate but the fact
is and and actually so now this is my
new educational mission if I have to
talk to non experts I try to teach them
the idea that we don't operate we
operate at least one or maybe many
levels of abstraction about that and we
say oh here's a hypothesis class maybe
it's a space of plans or maybe it's a
space of classifiers or whatever but
there's some set of answers and an
objective function and then we work on
some optimization method that tries to
optimize a solution a solution in that
class and we don't know what solution
that's going to come out right so I
think it's important to communicate that
so I read of course probably people who
listen to this they they know that
lesson but I think it's really critical
to communicate that lesson and then lots
of people are now talking about you know
the value alignment problem so you want
to be sure as robots or software systems
get more competent that their objectives
are aligned with your objectives or that
our objectives are compatible in some
way or we have a good way of mediating
when they have different objectives and
so I think it is important to start
thinking in terms like
you don't have to be freaked out by the
robot apocalypse - except that it's
important to think about objective
functions of value alignment yes and
that you have to really everyone who's
done optimization knows that you have to
be careful what you wish for that ah you
know sometimes you get the optimal
solution and you realize man that was
that objective was wrong so
pragmatically in the shortest term it
seems to me that that those are really
interesting and critical questions and
the idea that we're gonna go from being
people who engineer algorithms to being
people who engineer objective functions
I think that's that's definitely going
to happen and that's gonna change our
thinking and methodology and we're gonna
you started at Stanford philosophy
that's where she comes I will go back to
because as we also know as machine
learning people right when you're design
in fact this is the lecture I gave in
class today when you design an objective
function you have to worry about with
hats
there's the Hat that says what do I want
and there's the hat that says but I know
what my optimizer can do to some degree
and I have to take that into account
okay so it's it's always a trade-off and
we have to kind of be mindful of that
the part about taking people's jobs I
understand that that's important I don't
understand sociology or economics or
people very well so I don't know how to
think about that so that's yeah so there
might be a sociological aspect there the
economical aspect that's very difficult
to say well okay I mean I think other
people should be thinking about it but
I'm just that's not my strength so what
do you think is the most exciting area
of research in the short term for the
community and for your for yourself well
so I mean there's the story I've been
telling about how to engineer
intelligent robots so that's what we
want to do we all kind of want to do
well I mean some set of us want to do
this and the question is what's the most
effective strategy and we've tried and
there's a bunch of different things you
could do at the extremes right one super
extreme is we do introspection then we
write a program okay that has not worked
out very well
another extreme is we take a giant bunch
of neural
and we trying to train it up to do
something I don't think that's gonna
work either so the question is what's
the middle ground and and again this
isn't a theological question or anything
like that it's just like going how do
just how do we what's the best way to
make this work out and I think it's
clear it's a combination of learning to
me it's clear it's a combination of
learning and not learning and what
should that combination be and what's
the stuff we built in so to me that's
the most compelling question and when
you say engineer robots you mean
engineering systems that work in the
real world is that that's the emphasis
last question which robots
or robot is your favorite from science
fiction so you can go with Star Wars
Arthur r2d2 or you can go with more
modern maybe Hal this is this is back to
you like to make robots work in the real
world here not Madden I mean I love the
process and I care more about the
process engineering process yeah I mean
I do research because it's fun not
because I care about what we produce
well that's a that's a beautiful note
actually to end on Leslie thank you so
much for talking today sure it's been
fun
you